to X plus y equal to four is a linear
equation as it is linear its graph will
be a straight line how do we plot the
graph though to draw any line we need a
minimum of two points and to find the
points we can substitute different
values in place of X and get
corresponding values for y let's say X
is 1 Y will be 4 minus 2 which is 2 1
comma 2 will be the coordinates of one
of the points now let's try X equal to 2
we get the value of y as 4 minus 4 which
is 0 so 2 comma 0 will be the
coordinates of the second point with
these two points we can easily draw a
line for this equation on the coordinate
plane where will 1 comma 2 be located
1 2 here this will be 1 comma 2
similarly 2 comma 0 will be located here
and this is the line of 2 X plus y equal
to 4 just to verify if this line is
correctly drawn take another point on
the line and see if it satisfies this
equation take this point for instance 0
comma 4 if we substitute 0 in place of x
and 4 in place of Y we do get a 4 it
satisfies the equation there is an
interesting way to write this equation
we can transpose 2x to the other side
and write it as Y is equal to minus 2x
plus 4 but how does it make a difference
why write it this way writing the
equation this way gives us two important
things first it gives us the slope -2 is
the slope here and it gives us the
y-intercept of the line here 4 is the
y-intercept y-intercept is the point at
which the line intersects the y axis
isn't it amazing that just writing the
equation
zwei gives us two things straight away
the y-intercept we can see is full but
let's verify the slope it's y minus y1
over X minus x1 if we consider these two
points we get 2 minus 0 over 1 minus 2
that gives us minus 2 which is the same
as this equation gives us this is called
the slope-intercept form the general
form is y is equal to MX plus b where m
is the slope and b is the y-intercept
where else can we apply this concept
look at the next equation we are asked
which quadrants does the line of this
equation pass through give it a try
equation pass through the best way would
be to write this equation in the
slope-intercept form rearranging the
terms we write it as y is equal to 2x
plus 7/2 is the slope and 7 is the y
intercept of this line let's look at it
on the coordinate plane the y-intercept
is 7 it will be somewhere here 0 comma 7
the slope is positive so the line cannot
be like this or like this these lines
have a negative slope it has to be
tilted in the other way it will look a
bit like this that's all we can see that
the line passes through the first second
and the third quadrant we didn't really
need to draw the exact line to get to
the answer the slope-intercept form was
enough to tell us the quadrants through
which the line passes